so happy to be here to be interviewing
Cheryl it feels really synchronistic
that I'm I'm here today I came across
Cheryl's work about a year and a bit ago
where I was doing the school run for my
Penuel son and one of my friends we live
I live in a tiny little village in
Sussex and she my friend is all blotchy
she came to us it up people right it
just be weird a bit oh and my friend she
happens to be um radio for was book
editor which it's very nice
oh yeah whatever so I took the book and
and the next time it makes the school
run that was new or blocked so the first
time I came across you you made me cry
but I just wanted to say big thank you I
think the book wild touched a nerve in
me about grief and healing that perhaps
other books have never reached for me I
lost my parents also when I was teenager
so for me to be able to read about war
grief in such a strong and beautiful way
and also showing a way out
showing somebody's actually understood
how I was feeling it was it was just
absolute credible science really really
delighted to be talking to Cheryl today
thank you so much and so I just wanted
to so started off on the journey I just
want you to describe a scene when you
decided I am going to go off on a
journey of 1,100 miles on the Pacific
Crest Trail scribe to me the decision
that you made and why you made it well I
was at this time in my life that I
really the only way to accurately
describe it is to say I was at this
place that I think was the bottom point
I had been in deep grief over the death
of my mother she'd been dead at this
point about three and a half years and I
might by this point my marriage hadn't
raveled I was only 26 but I got married
really young to somebody who was who I
loved who was a good person and but I
but I knew that I couldn't
stay with him I didn't want to stay with
him I didn't want to be married to
anyone but that was incredibly
heartbreaking for me nonetheless because
he was the you know I loved him and he
loved me and in my sorrow I did I did
what a lot of people do I grieved in
ways that I think were noble and the
ways that we all hope that will grieve
and then I agreed in ways that were
self-destructive and and in you know in
ways that actually brought more grief
and in my case it was really promiscuous
sex and then eventually drug use I one
of the guys that I became involved with
those of you who've read Wilde know he
introduced me to heroin and I began he's
in heroin and when I used you know it's
really interesting
now the the 45 year old me can look back
on the the 20-something me and see very
clearly that that actually my impulse to
use heroin was the same impulse that
brought me to hike that trail and that I
was really seeking a cure for pain I was
trying to heal and when I used heroin it
actually the first feeling the first
feeling I had was that I was safe now
that it that I was I had escaped my
sorrow finally there was something that
could actually lift this this weight
that I was carrying and it was Planet
heroin but was it was it that was it
numbing for me it was I spent a lot of
time just numbing write whatever I could
in unhealthy and healthy ways but
whatever it was right of course it
wasn't that but what I've seen is it
felt like that for a moment and of
course what what happened on that next
moment is that you know my life then
really did start falling apart in a
pretty serious way because of of drug
use and and you know so I was at this
place I was I was at the bottom full of
regret full of remorse full of you know
why am I even here and I found out I was
pregnant by the man the heroin addict
boyfriend
and that was where I just thought okay I
cannot do this I cannot live this life
this is not me and it wasn't so much
that I felt the need to save myself
because I really felt at that time that
I was really a worthless person but I
knew that I could not my mother had
loved me too well for me to destroy
myself I couldn't disrespect my mother
that much I I had to honor her and and I
think in some ways I thought that
self-destruction and deep grief I was
honoring my mother because I couldn't go
on without her I couldn't thrive and and
suddenly I had this revelation
I guess it's it's like that real gay
poem where you know that culminates in
the you know you must change your life
and it was that I must change my life
and and and I had to find a way I had
scattered I had to find a way to gather
and so I decided to like the Pacific
Crest Trail okay so there's a bit of a
gap there so eat so you in this this
dark dark place and many of those would
have chosen at a counselling maybe I
know you know how did you how were you
inspired to do that why why did you
think that was the solution wet well you
know those of you who are familiar with
my dear sugar column I always tell
people to trust the gut to trust the
body the body knows and there I was
living at the time in Minnesota which is
very cold place lots of snow and there
had been a blizzard and my truck was
buried in snow and I needed to dig it
out and I went to this outdoor store
called REI to buy a shovel and when I
was waiting in line to pay for the
shovel I saw a guidebook that was the
book just said Pacific Crest Trail
Volume one California and I picked it up
I'd never heard of the Pacific Crest
Trail had any of you heard of the
Pacific Crest Trail before even many
Americans still haven't heard it I mean
they heard of it through wild and I just
turned the back over and read this
paragraph about this trail and what
happened inside of me was I felt this
blossoming and I just thought
I this is a magnificent beautiful thing
and what if you know maybe I just need
to go to that thing attach myself to
that thing and I just trusted that
feeling even though there were you know
problems with that namely that you know
I'd never gone backpacking before and
stuff like that but I've always been a
little fuzzy on you know the details of
things but um the idea I'm an idea woman
you know so that's what's so amazing I'm
gonna do that for all and off we go and
then think oh you know what I can't be
bothered is the kind of Joseph Campbell
thing yeah where there's the invitation
and you like it and then there's a
refusal like nah not really
yo you know what-what were you why did
you continue you know so you had that
moment of right this is it a blossoming
and then did you have any doubt or did
you were you very determined that you
were going to do it no I had a lot of
doubts and you know all along the way
you know preparing for the trip and
switch off your mobile preparing I've
always wanted to just answer the phone
on stage from somebody and see what
happened but um preparing for the the
trip you know many people I would tell
them what I was doing and especially you
know my friends you know my friends who
had witnessed all this you know like
sleeping with you know all these people
and doing heroin and you know they're
all freaked out by what I've been up to
and then I'm like okay now I'm gonna go
hide this truck and they were all saying
that they roll their eyes it's like yeah
well they said what what do you you know
maybe are you sure you need to do this
and isn't this dangerous and you know my
joke was always like not as dangerous as
shooting heroin but um and and it isn't
actually statistically it's safer to
so I highly recommend that over heroin
if any of you are but you know and then
I the time the biggest out I think was
the night before my hike when I you know
checked into this motel and looked at
all the I had to carry and I
thought maybe I didn't think this all
the way through and so that was Tommy
about monster that introduces the
monster think most of me that made me
laugh so much is that you were there at
the first was it the first time you'd
actually packed your bag at that point
yes I I had never packed my backpack
until the day I began backpacking and
you know you're really when you're going
on a you know a hundred day or so
journey it is a good idea to take the
pack out on a trial run and things like
that and so I didn't do that and III for
the first time packed my pack and not
everything would fit it was an awful lot
of stuff it and the pack was really
heavy I mean sort of unbelievably so you
know like just really wasn't the half of
your body weight at least that I mean
what's interesting right now
the the film of wild is being made and
they so we'll get back to monster in a
minute but just let me tell you this bit
because people always say well how much
did your pack way and the only thing
that I did not bring on the trail was a
scale so I I don't know how much it
weighed but it weighed a whole lot and
so right now the film of wild is being
made and Reese Witherspoon is playing me
and she's dressed exactly like me in
1995 on the trail they have read I still
have my backpack and so they they
borrowed it and then they recreated the
pack exactly exactly the way I packed it
everything and so they have on the set
you know a few different packs for
different scenes you know in one weighs
like 25 pounds and one weighs like forty
five pounds in one weighs like sixty
five pounds and they and she wears it
depending on what she's doing and so at
one point I was like well we I think she
should wear the heaviest pack in the
scene and so they they had me go like
show her how to I put it on and I lifted
it and it was
like no problem sixty-five pounds and my
pack was so my back was definitely at
heavier it's like 80 85 maybe 90 just
the water alone on the first day was
twenty four pounds just the water
everything else was so um it was a lot
and I had been out on the trail a few
days when the I gave the packing
nicknamed monster and I'd referred to it
as monster and you know I didn't know
later that I would write a book about it
and it would be actually have sort of
metaphorical residence too that I'm
walking along with the monster you know
on my back like we all do um in life
yeah yeah well the irony is is you have
your book inspired me so much that last
summer I decided I was going to take my
own trek down the Cornwall coast and
like you I packed my bag with my tent I
lasted half a day before I put my tent
up at the one I said I used to walk and
then get the bus back I didn't take the
but there were no buses on the PCT sadly
but yeah it was hard wasn't it it was
really really hard and you know but one
of the things I really resonated with
you made the decision to go and there
was a quote in the book it say I could
go back in the direction I had come from
well I could go forward in that
direction I intended to go and it was a
decision you made and I think when when
you know it's it's that decision that
you've made you've lost your mum there's
two ways you can go you can go down
self-destruction heroin there are spiral
down or you can go on the PCT and you
can go and walk along those tell me
about that decision that you made it
where did you find how did you talked
about that blossoming but where did you
find that kind of the wisdom or the
knowledge that that to keep on walking
to take those steps and not get the bus
I don't really know but I know that I
know a few things one is that you know
that that seemed that the line you quote
what's just happened right before I
wrote that line is I've just
been basically almost mauled by a Texas
Longhorn bull and in the final moment as
this ball is you know approaching me I'm
so afraid that I closed my eyes because
I can't bear to look at this bull and
the fate I mean it's like this I don't
know if any of you have ever seen a
Texas Longhorn bull it's a very very
gigantic thing with horns okay and it's
scary and so I close my eyes that I blew
the whistle the world's loudest whistle
really loud and I when I open my eyes
the bull is not there and so then the
question is well which way is the bull
and okay whatever way the bull is I
don't want to walk in that direction
okay so and that's and in the book you
know now after years of thinking about
this moment I understood it I understood
it's metaphorical resonance with I said
I essentially all of us everyone in this
room like what we always have to do and
the deal is is that there's no escaping
the bull
you know the bull is in every direction
and I think that when we try to escape
suffering or try to escape fear or
discomfort or truce or any of those
things that can be difficult we think
okay that's that's over there so I'm
going to go this way but guess what it's
that way and until you kind of just
decide that you can give yourself over
to walking in the direction of the bull
you're never going to you're never going
to do what you need to do I think as a
human to evolve and so I think that I
don't know if that answers your question
really exactly but I guess I started to
learn that at some point what I'm
hearing you say is that peace around
it's not overcoming fear we never
overcome our fear or grief we don't know
convert we just learn to be with it
mm-hmm and I think my mistake has been
trying to escape grief or trying to
escape fear anything rather than being
the run away from the bull as fast as I
can but then there's the ball and there
he is I know and that's it before we
came out here we talked about you know
losing our parents and how you know so
much of understanding grief had to do
with understanding that we would always
have it yeah you know that we were back
there getting tears in our eyes talking
about our mothers and there it was you
know our moms have been dead more than
20 years and there it still is and I
think that except you know giving
yourself into that and saying this is
this isn't something that's going to go
away there's something that will always
be with me
and learning how to live with it is a
more healing and powerful experience
than than escaping it yeah I mean you
talk I think India sugars this idea of
reaching you you were a mentor for some
young teenage girls this is a brilliant
piece and only tiny beautiful things and
you say to them reach you have to do
more than hold on you have to find a way
within yourself to not only escape the
but transcend it and I just for me again
I was like welling up crying once again
to but it's that that piece around we
can't escape it we can't wriggle out
away we can't get out the way of grief
or the darkness but we have to find a
way to transcend it right somehow and I
suppose what my question is is how do we
do that well what would your advice to
us be how do we reach how do we
transcend that yes acceptance but it's
always there but then then where do we
go yes acceptance that it's there beside
us but then we're I think so I was going
to say acceptance surrender but I think
the other thing is and here again so
much of the the advice I give is sugar
you know is advice of the spirit rather
than do this and this and then this it's
rather a sort of bigger more Universal
advice which has to do with taking
responsibility for your life and so yeah
on the trail you know the thing I had to
do was just keep moving forward even
when it was painful and I think that
that was in that physically enacting
what I need that we ought what we all
need to do
over and over again when we have
something that's difficult and so I
think transcending and in reaching and
in that column you refer to which is
called how you get unstuck what I'm
saying to these teenage girls these
teenage girls have every reason to fail
they have every reason to to you know
become pregnant at 15 or go to prison or
you know whatever it is that that their
parents most of them had done they could
blame their abusive parents they could
blame poverty they could blame any
number of social factors but ultimately
in that column what I said and what I
said to the girls I worked with is you
know you have to be the person who
changes your life nobody will ever
change your life for you you have to be
that person and so transcending has to
do I think with taking responsibility
that word means moving from one realm to
another you know and so your life is
here and if you want it to be there
you're the one who has to get it there
and there are a whole bunch of things
you need to do to make that happen it
doesn't have to do with you know sitting
around saying over and over again that
you want to go there it has to do with
walking yourself there one step at a
time I think we're working with those
girls was so fascinating to me because
we would do this career day and they
would we would they would get to write
down on a piece of paper what they
wanted to be when they grow up and then
tape it to their shirts and then we
would you know talk to them about that
career and it was always they all wanted
to be pediatricians or marine biologists
pretty much all of them and and but then
they hated school and they would never
do their homework and they would never
do any of those things and so I would
say well how are you going to you know
you don't just like grab a bunny out of
a hat and then you're a pediatrician
like how are you going to do that and I
think that that has to do with that
taking responsibility peace that one
step at a time peace I think it's a
taking responsibility but then I think
it is that what so I think inspiring
about the journey and wild it was
literally one physical step at a time
it's a very simple message in a way it
is so simple okay I can't do this well
you can take a step though you can and
then you can take another one even if
you have got a monster on your back and
I'm
trail one of the most I think useful
things and powerful things for me was
that I was you know I was the person who
every consequence I was someone who paid
the full price every day I paid the
consequences ever every action I had the
consequence and sometimes it was a
positive one and sometimes a negative
one but it was just me and myself and I
wasn't depending on anyone else there
was really important for me to go along
but I think again the story again why
it's so inspiring is it's that it's the
story of the orphan who learns to stand
on her own two feet and to be strong
again and I think no there's maybe the
proverbial orphan yeah in all of us who
were learning how to how to you know how
to take a step and how to learn that we
are strong despite facing all the
difficulties that you may face in life
right it's it's wonderful in terms of
you did rattlesnakes you did bad did the
scary campers scary I mean did you ever
feel I don't know what I'm going to do
now did you know I mean I know from
reading the book mm-hmm
the answer to that but tell me a little
bit about the those moments of intense
fear yeah at the right there were a few
and I always felt like I wanted to run
away shrieking you know and I instead
had to sit quietly and figure out my way
through it and and I think that that um
you know doubt I mean I think sometimes
when we think about you know whether it
be like people will say oh you're right
so you're so brave on the page and I'm
always like I'm terrified I'm actually
terrified writing that stuff and I think
that we have you know all all of us in
some ways misinterpreted you know how
we're supposed to feel it when it comes
to things like fear you know I I wasn't
courageous on the PCT I was often afraid
but I think getting used to fear or
saying okay I'm afraid of this and I can
to keep going this was a big you know I
was facing that almost every day and
fear of things like um you know I think
we think of rattlesnakes is scary
right but really the scariest situation
I was probably in on my hike was when I
ran out of water you know that was a
like I was terrified
I knew the consequences of that and they
were grave you know and so I think that
that I was in some ways looking for that
too you know when I say when I said that
you know decided to use heroin it was
like hiking the trail in one way and
that is you know I was in some ways
needing to test myself against something
which is a really ancient human as you
know story where you know that the
hero's journey has to do with going into
the darkness and facing the demons in
the Dragons and and coming back from
that experience changed and I was aware
that that's you know I was giving myself
my own rite of passage yeah you know our
culture's have kind of missed that
I think but do you think it needs to be
that scary or can some of us just get
the boss thank you you have to take the
bus yeah no I
that's what's have been so cool is it's
not I mean the other thing is to you
know many many people have taken far you
know greater adventures than mine like I
don't the point of wild is not like look
at me I did this incredible thing you
know I actually did a very you know I
mean many people have have hiked better
and further you know braver but the
point is look at that this is the
journey I went on and I think that
people's everyone's journey can look a
different way you know and I get so many
emails from people saying well just like
you said oh I took this 50 mile hike in
this place or I did this you know people
make it their own and it's really about
the journey yeah yeah you talked about
being brave on the page and so you've
written about the trail after you've
taken the actual journey and you're
brave how how how have you done that you
know in terms of literally being brave
on the page I mean the thing that's so
attractive about the book that you want
to just you can't leave it it's because
it's so raw and it's so devastating
almost the way you write and you've been
so vulnerable on the page so brave on
the page but how how could you do that
you know
having so much time brass or is it
because so much time has passed that you
were able to do that right you know I
think um yeah I didn't think I was going
to write about my hike until I did I
began writing the book in 2008 and you
know I'm just as a writer I think really
or the writers job is to tell the truth
it's it's it and and not just the truth
but the deepest truth the deepest truth
that can be possibly uncovered the this
the darkest and brightest place that we
can go I think that that's what artists
do that's what they show to us that's
what they reveal to us and so I really
feel that that's my job as a writer
whether I'm writing about a fictional
character or myself to go to all of
those places and you know if you don't
do that you haven't done your work and I
think that that's connected to the
reason that I didn't feel like writing
about my hike until I did that I needed
to to come to that place as a writer to
learn you know just to apprentice myself
to the gaffed for a number of years and
also I had to gain some perspective on
that person I was at 26 yeah I began
writing it when I was like 38 or 39 and
I could look back I was in a very
different place I could look back at
myself it with a you know both this
objective lens but in some ways an
objective one too and and so that's you
know I waited because I needed to gain
that perspective and also my first book
is a novel called torch and that was the
book that I had to write I couldn't
think about writing anything until I got
that out of my system
and that book is going to be published
in the UK yes here and a few months that
one book I haven't read out of your so
I'm looking forward to reading that so
when you were writing sort of 21 20
years on now from when you were 18 years
on 18 Yin I mean since the hike yeah so
happy looking back do you think what did
you learn on the hike and have you put
those lessons into action 20 years on
you you know you look about the way
you're living your life have you are you
living breathing those essence now yes I
mean that that is the thing
about any difficult any any difficult
experience or beautiful experience or
you know life-altering experiences that
you carry it with you yeah you know you
carry it with you into your life and
you're forever changed because of it and
so there's no question in my mind that
you know everyday I mean there are all
these places I mean I think that that I
would still be where I am
had I not hike the PCT but I had to have
some journey like that I had to have
some big experience to shake myself back
into my real life for the person I
needed to be and you think the
wilderness what part did the wilderness
and I mean your story I mean we we did a
whole dossier at psychologies magazine
around wilderness it was inspired by
your book you know I wrote about you in
the Sunday Times inspired by your book I
want to thank you it's so but I do feel
like the wilderness is a very you know
even though I was getting the but it was
still I was on the coast of Cornwall
going up and down I know I love the
wilderness here there's a bus yeah right
kind of wilderness you need love can I
just say but tell me a little bit what
what role do you think the wilderness
plays in your healing or why do you
think it's healing I think that it's
well just I mean how do you all feel
when you go into the wilderness that you
just feel kind of healed you know I
think that when we put ourselves in the
company of the derivative of the divine
which I think the wilderness is the
magnificent the bigger than us we feel
humble and we feel grace filled and we
feel restored and serene and all of
those things I mean unless you're
flipping out because there's a
rattlesnake at your feet but you know
you feel those things and so I knew you
know when I grown up in northern
Minnesota for my teen years when I was
12 my stepfather who was a carpenter
fell from a roof and broke his back and
we lived at the time this little town
outside of Minneapolis and
my stepfather had been working under the
table which means you know none he
wasn't like document I mean he wasn't
officially being paid by his boss and so
when he fell from the roof and broke his
back his boss said I don't know that man
he didn't work for me and there was it
was a terrible difficult year of my
stepfather was laid up and you know with
a broken back for a year and my mother
at the time was working as a secretary
for an attorney and the attorney said
I'll bring a suit against your your
husband's boss and you know you guys can
get a settlement and my and they won the
settlement and my parents got $12,000
and we repor and it was really the the
only money that my that they knew they
knew that was the only time they would
have any bit of money to buy some land
and so they did they went to northern
Minnesota land was really cheap it still
is really cheap and for $12,000 they
bought 40 acres of land that nobody had
ever lived on wilderness woods cold
really cold and we moved onto this land
and we lived it in one room tarpaper
Shack that my stepfather built my family
of five and we built our house nearby
and we lived in this house we didn't
have electricity or indoor plumbing or
running water or anything all through my
teen years Wow
we would you know heat up we our wood
stove was a metal barrel a 55-gallon
barrel that my stepfather had used his
his blowtorch and made into a wood stove
yeah and we lived this way and this kind
of back-to-the-land way my mom grew a
lot of our food and made our clothes and
you know did all of that stuff and um
and I think in so many ways so the
wilderness was home to me yeah and when
my mom died things happened with my
stepfather that made it so that that
place that home that we built together
was not my home anymore was not I was
exiled from this place and by my
stepfather got involved with another
woman pretty quickly after my mom died
and
she didn't really want us my siblings
and I around and so you know it was lost
to me and you know all these years later
when I was writing wild is when I
understood that that in some ways when I
decided to hike the PCT I was turning to
her even though it was a foreign home
you know it was this other place I knew
that it was a place that I could be safe
and find myself again yeah and it was a
place that was familiar it was that
comfort yeah and even though it was a
different I mean so I didn't have that
sort of City idea
I was I was afraid of the city actually
when I went to college in the Twin
Cities
that's Minneapolis and st. Paul in
Minnesota I was you know terrified of
all the city people cuz they did City
things like they drove fast you know
yeah I mean I read I'm aware of Redax I
did a little bit research but this thing
around you knew you wanted to be a
writer even though you were brought up
in a kind of your were think uneducated
way but in a way the way your mother
brought you up was incredibly creative
yes you know it may be that she you know
you wouldn't perhaps have posh drinks
that's right so she would put something
in the water and say we put a lot of
beer
uh-huh you know um darling let's have
some pain she would speak in a British
accent because did you because you don't
charge America's anything British is
instantly like more sophisticated uhm
but yeah we didn't there would be times
that we didn't have sugar we and my
mother would put food coloring in the
water and she would be miss Bettina
Vaughn so and so and she would um she
would say darling would you like I won't
do my British accent to you guys um but
would you like another you know and we
would do this fan pretend drinks but
that was my mom you know and that was
she brought magic into our lives and she
would always say and which made me when
I was a teenager want to like smother
her but she would say we aren't poor
were rich in love and you know she was
very looking on the bright side and
which you know when you're 17 you do not
appreciate right
and but I mean as is the case maybe some
of you have found this to be true in
your life to that you know you look back
on some of those things that your
parents said to you or you know annoyed
you about or whatever and then you you
grow older and you look back and you see
that they've they've actually were right
and that they actually had to do the
tools for your own survival and I think
that that's really the case and with my
mother you know that her optimism
eventually became you know the worldview
that I had to take on and and also you
know she made us feel rich we were rich
in love yeah we were and and you know I
have friends who were rich in material
and and poor in love and I wouldn't
trade places with them for anything I
think what was really interesting as
well for me was this idea of how she
created a an environment where
creativity buttoned down
and so in perhaps in your environment it
was it wasn't the done thing to be a
writer perhaps you would move it be you
both went to college together didn't you
at the same time that right yeah we did
so how that happened so when I went you
know I I always knew I wanted to be a
writer from the very first time I could
read I just was I mean I I distinctly
remember the moment you know it was an
epiphany and I I did my family didn't go
to church but I was I spent the night
with a friend on a Saturday night and
when I woke up on Sunday morning her
family attended a Lutheran Church and so
I had to go with them and we were put
off into the Sunday school and there was
this little pamphlet that they handed
out to all the kids and it was really a
chapbook of watercolors and each
watercolor was accompanied by a little
poem that was about you know the sort of
God's glory in the natural world like
the you know little riffs on butterflies
and sunsets and flowers and I remember
reading it and thinking I mean just
being pierced by the beauty I mean
really pierced by the beauty of those
words and what words could do which was
make a feeling in the picture and I
to do that I wanted to be a person in
the world who who made Beauty have
language six-six and I just thought I
have to do this thing and I'd never
thought it'd ever like it wasn't it I
didn't know that I someone like me could
actually be a writer I thought I didn't
know what the route was but I knew that
college would be part of it but so when
I was in high school nobody told me you
know what you need to do to go to
college and so when I was in my senior
year in high school I just started to
get brochures from colleges they start
to you know send you things and I didn't
know it was a competitive process really
that you should apply to more than one
or anything and so I just lined up the
brochures on my table and I looked at
the pictures and the one that looked the
least weird you know was the one I
applied to and it was the college of st.
Thomas which is a private Catholic
school private and public means
different things here right yeah it
means it cost a lot of money private
Catholic University in Saint Paul
Minnesota and when they accepted me they
were trying to woo me to come there
because they didn't realize that you
know they were they were the only game
in town for me
and um they said one of the things if
you go your parents can go to college
for free and you know they were thinking
like somebody's mom would take like
French you know 101 or something but my
mother saw this and she said I've always
wanted to go to college and I said no
way
because would any of you at the age of
17 have volunteered to bring your mom
raise raise your hand raise your hand if
you wanted to bring your mom so I was
like no way you're not going to college
with me get that idea out of your head
and then you know what what happened is
of course you know there's the true
thing which is no way
and then there's the true thing which is
my mother has given me so much and then
the truest thing is that you know that I
couldn't stand in the way of her
opportunity and so I said to her you can
go to college with me with one rule is
that should we ever encounter each other
on campus she cannot show any
recognition do not address me do not
twice just keep on going off and she was
like okay that's fine and she was so
respectful that this was this moment in
my life where I needed to separate you
know she was serially and she was 40 and
I just remember thinking I can't believe
somebody so ancient is going to college
and and and so we went that first year
together and it wasn't a good fit for me
I was paying my own way through and it
was just too expensive and it was a
conservative school and and you know I
was a writer and so I went to my mom and
said look I need to I'm going to
transfer and she said you know that's
fine I'll transfer to and so she did and
we went to the same we went to the
University of Minnesota but thankfully
there were more than there's more than
one campus so I went in Minneapolis and
she went up in Duluth which was nearer
our house about an hour and a half away
from our house I mean what occurs to me
as you're talking is I mean you had that
lovely time yeah you know use your
teenage mother yeah type of relationship
but you had a fantastic relationship
with mother as you've told in wild how
do you think that has impacted the way
you are a mother today you think you
know for me I think I apparent just like
my mother which is terrible to go up for
you how do you parent your children
because you've got two children yes I
have two kids
I feel like did I parent them very much
the way my mom parented me my kids have
a profoundly different life than I had
um as a kid they just you know do you
think that's a good thing I do I do i
worry you know I mean I feel like so
much of of ever you know so much of Who
I am was kind of learned through my
hardscrabble childhood yeah I mean I
grew up in poverty you know I learned a
lot from that um and my kids you know
just have a diminutive to parents who
have master's degrees in the arts you
know their father is a filmmaker I'm a
writer they they you know they just get
to have a different kind of life and so
I do worry about them just not having to
kind of you know work as hard frankly as
I had to work yeah but on the other hand
I I love that they have some I mean you
know the thing that that I think made me
cry the hardest since all this stuff has
happened with while is um is I bought a
piano for my kids and it started they
started piano lessons and I just always
wanted to have piano lessons my whole
life and I never got to and ice now I'm
too busy to take piano lessons but I
gave them to my kids you know my kids
get to be the kids who get piano lessons
you know and so that's a big deal and
any of you who grew up you know and
we're able to give your kids what you
didn't get it's just a powerful
experience you know and so yeah that's
that's an eye but the way I parent them
essentially you know is the same way my
mother did with love with a great amount
of love and openness about that love you
know I did not
my mother didn't ever withhold when my
mom found out she was dying and she died
seven weeks later I distinctly remember
us talking about how he was like okay
this is our last chance with each other
right she's going to die and the coolest
thing was that there was nothing we had
to say to each other
there was nothing that we had to say to
each other because we'd already said it
there were no there were no like secrets
or things that had gone unsaid or
unresolved it was all present already I
knew
that and my mother did too I feel so
lucky about that as you're talking I get
I still get that laughing lump in my
throat and let's not cry anyone crying
and but we were talking a little bit
about that gives the idea of the raw
grief and how it changes I know for me
reading the book can you hit every note
of that and it's not very often you get
someone who hits that note and it for me
it was like she gets it she understands
and do you think your grief has changed
over the years yeah I do yeah now first
for those of you who haven't read the
book it's also very funny in parts right
right
have any of you read as some of you have
read wild it and there were there were
funny parts right funny things okay um
but the green sari upset they're also
sad parts but there's funny friends I
always say to people you know sometimes
I'll get an email and they'll be like I
just finished chapter what and I don't
know if I can go on I'm like it gets
funny just keep reading it hold on baby
um just I let them get to the horse oh
no it was no whoa oh God so oh that's a
terrible scene I apologize for the horse
I even writing it I was like if I were a
reader I would just skip right past this
you know but grief you know how is my
crib changed it's absolute you know it
it was so enormous and monumental you
know in the years right after my mom
died and what's what's interesting about
it is it's still incredibly powerful I
can still you know every day I feel the
absence of my mother but it absolutely
does become you know more manageable
more part of life and and and I have a
deeper and more complex understanding of
of how I can carry it with me with some
some grace and without being ruled by it
or destroyed things or destroyed by it
yeah and so and so it gets easier even
though it's still there
you know and the beauty I mean the
beautiful thing about deep grief and
those of you who have lost somebody
essential to you I know you know what I
mean about this is the
is what it's really about is love you
know the only reason that you still
grieve somebody 23 years after they died
is because you actually truly really
loved them
and isn't that amazing I mean that's
just amazes me like I really loved my
mom yeah yeah absolutely
so how is both I know um are you ever
worried what your children will say when
they read your work how do you feel
about them reading it for the first time
maybe is 1718 yeah they I think they're
really lucky to have a mom who's a
writer I would love to have access to
the interior lives of my parents now I
wouldn't have loved it when I was 17 and
I don't think that my kids it's not as
if you know when they turn 16 I'm going
to be like happy birthday kids but out
of my book times you get to know mommy
better um you know I I will warn them
about you know that maybe there will be
some things that they don't want to read
like right now they know this story I
went I went to their school my kids are
seven and nine and last year I went to
their school and gave a talk and it I
was more nervous for that talk than any
talk and um so what was interesting to
me is you know obviously there were
pieces of the book that I that I
couldn't talk about in specific terms
but you know I could talk about more
more about the book than maybe you would
first think because one of the things I
decided when I went in is I wasn't going
to just tell them about the hike I was
going to tell them about grief and
because there's there's always you know
we assume the children I don't know why
we assume this the children don't know
about grief but there's always one
person in the room who whose dad died or
his mom died or who you know and so I
put up I did slideshows the only group
for whom I've done a slideshow in all of
my wild talking and I the first slide
was a picture of my mom and I said I
explained to them that my mom died and I
was so sad
that I didn't know what to do so I went
on a long walk and the kids were just
absolutely riveted by that portion of my
lecture and then I went on and gave the
hike you know they talked about the hike
and afterwards the kids went back to
their classrooms and they were all asked
to draw a picture about my talk and at
least half of them drew portraits of my
mom and it was because that was the part
that touched them the most that meant
that they connected with them so you
know I talked to them about the human
element of the book you know that this
is why I did this thing and you know
there are some sex scenes in the book
and there's some drug stuff and my kids
will probably be uncomfortable with it
and they'll wait until they're old
enough that they can handle it and then
they'll handle it
you know and that's the thing about it
about your momís you know you you have
the mom you have and and we all learn to
live with that and the mom they have
just happens to be you know somebody who
writes excruciatingly ly honest things
about myself you know and I'm sure you
know they'll have something to say
should I ever really start writing
excruciating ly honest things about them
which which I will avoid doing but um
you know I just think that they'll be
okay and and and frankly fortunate
someday you know like when they're in
their 40s they'll be like yeah my mom
wrote a book but you know um before that
I understand it's like my brother read
Wilde of course and um he loved the book
and we had a deep talk about it and but
he did say well when you were you know
at that scene when you're in Ashland and
you're like gonna have sex with that
hippie in the tent
he's like I just sort of had to skim
that part and I was like thank you you
know it's like I don't need to read that
stuff about my sister oh so um would you
do the trail again
of course I would would you yes really
oh yes though you know I have to say
it's funny cuz so the film is being shot
and you know we're out there I don't
know how many of you have been on a film
set but it's you know it's it's grueling
it's really hard work it's long days and
you know most of the movie obviously is
outside and you're in the elements and
I'm watching Reese like hike along under
this pack I just ask you what is it like
seeing where the spa
paying yourself can we just have a
moment here how incredible that is wait
with I know I know it's so movie star is
playing you in what I mean what I know
it's small it's about real like I don't
even have words for it it's so straight
I mean there's so many times where I
just think okay what the is going
on yeah I mean like what's so weird you
know I mean but yeah it's very large and
there's Riis so yeah it's strange and so
you think you know on the film set and
there's a dump site and we're outside
and you know we're just pretending okay
we're just pretending that this woman's
out alone in the wilderness and you know
and there's like she's trying to make
the stove work and and what's so funny I
loved this
I loved this I was like okay so they're
there um she's trying to cook dinner and
of course all the props guys and stuff
are like lighting the stove for her and
everything unlike I didn't have any guys
out there and and the thing keeps going
out like it keeps over and over and I
like and it won't work and I'm like see
I wasn't such an idiot like even even
professionals can't get it to work and
I'm so everyone saw was this is what
what it's like so there's this whole
thing and there's this movie star and
she's dressed in clothes exactly like
what I was wearing and you know and
she's doing this thing and she'll and
there will be some times where she's in
the middle of the scene and suddenly
I'll remember like I'll have a almost
like a body memory of what it was like
what it was like to to be standing there
but no film crew around like just to be
alone in the wilderness and I'll go back
to that place in my mind and it was hard
and it was lonely and it was really
really profoundly solitary you know like
in every direction
there was no humans it was just me and I
mean sometimes four miles but you know
and there was at the first eight days
nobody 8 days nobody and I'll go back to
that and so like if I did the trail
again if I did it alone again which I
don't know that I would do that you know
I want to go with my husband and my kids
but if I did it alone again I know for
sure that it would be hard I've gone on
backpacking
trips by myself since then and even just
like the first few days it's like okay
this is not fun this is uncomfortable
need the bus the bus the bus is a good
thing the train but just to settle back
into that that that's sole onus is you
know it's difficult and just being with
yourself yeah and you know I only manage
five days and your own thoughts see
that's the other thing 1995 different
world know them now no phones no I mean
I didn't have any electronics with me I
didn't have music I didn't have any I
didn't have anything they didn't even I
mean the first time I heard about a cell
phone was strangely was on the PCT the
first time I saw a cell phone and um
this guy I call Albert in the book that
the Eagle Scout dude who helped me
lighten my pack
he had this brick of plastic I kid you
not with these buttons with numbers on
the front and I was like well what
what's that he said this thing
I'm gonna get rid of it he didn't say
because he's a Christian but um and
um he said I'm going to get rid of it
and he said some company is trying to
develop this thing it's called a cell
phone and they found out I was going on
this hike and they asked me to carry it
from Mexico to Canada and and turn it on
every hour or something to see if it
would get reception and I was like and
he goes and I've been walking for you
know a month now never got reception so
I'm not going to keep carrying I'm just
gonna leave it in the hiker free box so
somebody has like a cell phone prototype
out there right so and I remember us
distinctly and this is why I'm not in
product development saying that is the
stupidest idea I've ever and we were
like who on this green earth would agree
to carry a phone around with them all
the time I mean who would do that like
isn't it I mean why would you ever want
people to always be able to reach you
just thought it was absurd and we were
like that's gonna tank for sure so this
is why I'm a writer instead of us yeah
so yeah so so we've got we've had wild
it's been huge success and number one
best-selling on New York Times list tiny
beautiful things also number one
The Times list Oprah's what hopeful like
oh my god oh my mouse master
Oprah hello everything so do you want to
hear how Oprah it's a phone story a cell
phone story no it's okay no did you let
your sending that and the phone rang and
it will open people or did she ring you
direct tell me doctor okay I was in a
hotel room in Milwaukee I was wild had
been out you know a month or so I was
doing Wendy well anyway I was weld at
this point had already exceeded any time
I had for myself it was on the New York
Times bestseller list it was just and my
I was in Milwaukee Wisconsin and my cell
phone rang and Milwaukee's just maybe a
couple hours away from Chicago and it
was a Chicago number and I and I thought
it was this sales rep who I was gonna
meet later that day and so I almost let
a good a voicemail
now as I God just answered the phone I
said hi this is Cheryl and the other
voice said hi this is Oprah she ran
herself yeah no yeah she rang herself
and I said um I did you know I said no
it would be I pause well I posit that it
is because it was Oprah you know I'd
like it was her voice it was and I mean
when Oprah calls you you know it and on
till either side oh my god like hello
what you know what do you want and and
she said I just finished wild oh my god
you know and then she would and in her
Oprah voice you know and we had this
long conversation like 20 minutes which
I keep I kept interrupting her to scream
and swear at her and be like and um and
then she says after about 20 minutes she
says so I have an idea and nobody knew
about this yet just me and her okay she
says I have an idea
I would like to restart my book club for
wild what do you think about that and I
said well I think that sounds just fine
and she said you know I and she was like
she said I'm on your website right now
she my website which by the way I just
do myself you know and I'm still to this
day and she's like I see you're gonna be
in Los Angeles on Saturday would you
like to stay an extra day and come to my
house in Santa Barbara and I was like
okay and so I find myself you know in a
limousine on Sunday morning being
whisked to Oprah's house and I spent the
day with her and she's just so lovely
and and we just hung out at her place
and which is just a shack you know and I
mean Hannah and we shot this show she
has a show called super soul Sunday and
we you know had this Hulk on camera
conversation right yeah kind of like
we're doing here tonight and um and the
except we were surrounded by cameras and
stuff and and and then oh you saw the
supercell Sunday yeah yuichi and um
Oprah's people did my hair that night so
yeah so um but it was really fun and
then I just hung out with her and got to
know her and she's the warmest lovely I
mean we've stayed in touch he's so you
know real Oprah's exactly like she seems
on TV you know I mean she says I think
she could be where she is without being
the real thing yeah
well and that's what was so cool when I
talked to her about um books and her
book club
did she really choose his books that she
loves it you know and like any list
we're not gonna all love the same books
that you know write you know our friends
don't always love the books we love and
Oprah just has a lot of friends you know
so she just chooses them from her heart
and shares them with the world and yeah
that ended up being a great thing you
know for me a really nice thing I mean
where do you go from here so you if
you've been on the New York Times I've
had the output at least with the spoon
is playing you in the film and it's out
next year and what next what I think
we're after all that the only place you
can go as you leave your husband for
George Clooney
right my husband's pretty great yeah
don't tell him that
yeah somebody's tweeting that as we
speak right my husband's not on Twitter
so we're safe um you know where we go
really is I just write another book yeah
yeah I got a band you know what you're
gonna write next are you you know I just
am going I'm gonna just the thing is
it's the only way to write is to just
get back to that place that you've
originally began which is just you alone
in a room with a lot of anxiety and fear
and doubt but with a vision you know and
so I you know I don't know what's going
to come next and it's just I'm just
gonna write you know and the thing is
just that the other thing is I like I
doubt that
like I just I doubt that I'll ever write
another book that does as well in the
marketplace is wild you know an artist
has no control over that and when
something like wild happens it's just
like lightning struck and you know I
didn't try to make that happen what I
tried to do is I tried to write the best
book I could write which is what I did
with torch and what I did with tiny
beautiful things and what I've done with
everything I've ever written and so I'm
going to write that next thing and and
who knows what the world will think of
it and that's kind of just really not up
to me I was interviewing at Elizabeth
Gilbert for psychologies this issue
actually and she said exactly the same
you know in pray love
hello it was fantastic brilliant but I
had to go back she I mean she did
committed then she had to go back to her
first love which is right and she's just
got her new novel out now and it's just
about the artist channeling whatever
yeah comes and doing what she loves
right and then sometimes other people
love it and sometimes other people don't
and so you just have to keep the faith
with what's true you know with the basic
the essential the element you know and
so I plan to do that well whatever you
write if George gives me time to
whatever you're right I know I'm going
to absolutely love it
so I actually wanted to talk about do
sugar and just ask your questions cuz
that was really what hooked me and
especially you write a lot about
relationships and I know it's been
really comforting for me but you write
so honestly about betrayal and
infidelity these things are just really
terrible that and I know a lot of you
know and also you talk about mr. sugar
and then you came out as you know shows
dear sugar and I wonder how writing
honestly helped or what it did to your
relationships and how it did it
strengthen them did it you know what I
mean because it's hard for us too for me
well I can't just write you know and
that will change my relationships but
how did that honesty change your
relationships right yeah so one thing is
dear sugar I was anonymous meaning that
readers didn't know who sugar was can
you all still hear me um but I knew who
I was and I also knew that someday my
name would be on those columns so
everything I wrote as sugar I wrote as
Cheryl Strayed
and so for example there's a column
called a little Sully in your suite
where I write about my husband cheating
on me early in our relationship and
before I wrote about it you know I got a
question that I I knew that the right
answer was going to be um you know to
tell the truth about my relationship
rather than to you know just talk about
the the surface level the facade and so
I asked my husband I was like look you
know I want to write about this
experience we had and what do you think
about that and and he said oh do you
have two and I said well not if you
don't want me to and he said actually
you know you do it and he and I you know
just really support each other and trust
each other and he knew that that I would
write I mean first of all he and I you
know in our in our relationship you know
are at a place like there was nothing
that he read that I wrote that was a
surprise to him you know that we're very
intimate with each other we worked our
way all the way through that that
infidelity and back again and as I wrote
in the column you know
I'm actually really grateful that that
that happened when it did in I'm great I
mean this sounds so bizarre but it's
true I'm grateful that my husband
cheated on me early in our relationship
so that we could go to that other place
of honesty with each other and figure
out like what was the problem and and it
brought us to a deeper level and and and
you know I think anyone who has you know
bit I've been with my husband 18 years
you know and I'm we're very happy and we
love each other and there has also been
some difficulty along the way and that's
true in any relationship and so I wanted
to sort of share the truth of that you
know I always think it'd be so
interesting I don't know if you guys do
this here but in the United States
sometimes there will be like a 50th
wedding anniversary party and you know
that they write it up like in the paper
they'll be like so and so and so and so
they're celebrating 50 years their
marriages you know they had four kids
and they you know what lived in three
cities and they were you know and it
says all this stuff what I think would
always be so interesting if we had a
real one you know she was her
boss for three years but then they
figured it out and um you know like you
know that we really see the like
actually what happened and how do you
make a 50-year marriage work and it's
not all you know roses and rainbows
right and so I wanted his dear sugar to
tell that story and so what it's done I
mean it hasn't it hasn't done anything
to my marriage because like I said my
this was not new information to my
husband the stuff I wrote it was just a
piece of us that I decided to share now
one thing about my writing is I'm really
you know people say oh you're so honest
and open that's true and it's also true
that I don't write everything there are
whole huge swaths of my life about which
you know nothing and I think the people
forget that because there are huge
swaths of my life about which you know a
lot and so you know I'm very conscious
and careful my siblings they come up in
wild one of the questions I always get
is about my siblings and their they've
had I mean there are lots of stories
about my siblings that I didn't tell
because I wanted to protect their
privacy I didn't want to hurt
their feelings or in any way invade
their lives you know but so I'm always
making that judgment as a writer and I
do think on the other hand like I
mentioned that my brother read Wilde and
you know those of you read the book know
that he's in some of the books most
difficult scenes and my brother has had
a hard life and and here and he's he
didn't even graduate from high school he
doesn't he's not like a bookish you know
intellectual person but he read Wilde
and he understood it on every know in
the most sophisticated way and he and I
had the most profound conversation that
we've had with each other in our lives
because of Wilde and because I wrote
honestly about what I felt about him and
what happened and he said you know I
can't believe it that stuff you wrote
Cheryl he said you know I buried so much
of that and it just all I came it was it
was incredibly healing for him to read
the book and for us to talk you know I
think there's some that we're I think
most of us are so afraid of speaking the
truth because we think it will hurt
people or it will cause conflict and I'm
here to tell you that that actually you
know so many the opposite has happened
in my life so many things are healed and
when you bring light in so many things
are actually made better it's it's not
as scary as as you would think I have a
daughter who lost her mum at eleven
uh-huh and she was doing sort of stuff
that you were doing in your twenties
when she was fifteen and she struggled
with life a lot if there was any advice
I could give her what would it be
because she's still struggling at 13
she's 30 hmm she's 30 did you say 30
yeah she got to children's uh-huh yeah
you know the it's so hard um it's so
hard for me to just encapsulate you know
one one piece of advice one of the
things that I think has been really
helpful to me in my own life frankly is
books you know my recommendation you
know how can you help her as find the
books that have been enlightening to you
and give them to her
well then buy all of my books
you know really honestly tiny beautiful
things is full of advice the book is
advice and it's advice of the spirit and
and it has to do I mean the only way
that your daughter will change her life
is by changing her life you know you
cannot you cannot change it for her and
I know how I know how hard that is
because I have loved people before who
haven't changed in the ways that I hope
they will and and you just can't you
have to do it yourself and and pretty
much every sugar column says that in
different ways and so I do think that it
could be useful to her and also just
love her you know love her through it
and you know share with her your honest
opinions in ways that maybe oh yeah
there's this thing I write about it and
in tiny beautiful things these teenage
girls I worked with and for me it was a
really interesting mind shift we treated
these girls with what I call call
unconditional positive regard which is
different than saying everything they do
is okay you know so if one of the girls
I was working with was you know sleeping
with a 30 year old guy which you know
many of them were there like 14 I would
say you are doing the wrong thing you
know I would I would share my honest
opinion but from a place that's not
judgmental but rather holding them an
unconditional positive regard and I
think that that is the best thing that
we can do for the people we love who are
clearly harming themselves good luck I'm
sorry it's hard and you should really
read my books I'm seizing or at least
buy them you don't have to read them hi
Cheryl
hello we're I'm over here oh there we go
you've sort of come to my question um
you've mentioned the word honesty so
many times tonight living honest
in writing honestly but for me the word
that really is dominant particularly in
tiny beautiful things is compassion and
I've heard you use the word super love I
read it yeah go somewhere and I would
just love to hear you speak a little bit
about compassion or super love or how
you come from that place you know the
advice that you've given yeah that that
word super love some somebody asked me I
think I must have said it in response to
a question as you know somebody said
what's the best advice you've ever
gotten and from whom and what's the
worst advice the worst advice my
mother's mother my grandmother gave me
and when I was 14 she said I'm going to
give you one piece of advice never if
you when you get married never in all of
your life get fully naked in front of
your husband that was bad advice
don't you think really bad advice my
poor grandfather but anyway but my
mother I remember in this in the early
70s I was very I was born in 1968 so I
was pretty young and I remember seen a
photograph and I think it's a famous
photograph and if anyone knows what it
is please tell me because I've looked
for this photograph because I remember
it so vividly but I want to find it
again I don't know who took it but it's
a picture of there were American on some
college campus American protesters they
were protesting the Vietnam War and
there was this image of these these like
National Guard guys holding these guns
and this young woman had gone up to the
gun and put a flower in the barrel of
the gun have you seen that picture and I
was a little you know just maybe four or
five and I said to my mom I asked her to
explain this photo to me what's what's
happening here and she said that she
explained to me that that you know these
people were in disagreement about
something they were on other sides of an
issue and I said well why did they why
did the woman put the flower in the gun
and she said because she's trying to zap
him back she's trying to zap him with
super love
and she said that's always the best you
know way to approach somebody who who
doesn't like you or who disagrees with
you just zap them back with super love
so they said that you know it creates an
opening between you I think that was you
know really good advice and I think it
has to do with compassion you know that
word calm it's like to be with in
passion and I just I think that most of
us are really deeply compassionate from
the beginning you know anyone who's had
a child unless your child is a sociopath
for which I apologize you know but but
you know children have that kind of they
identify with everything they feel the
joy of the world in the pain of the
world and you know the coolest thing for
me as a mom is to try to explain hate to
my kids you know like when I've had to
explain homophobia or explain the
Holocaust or explain and my kids are
just like they don't understand they do
not understand it and it's because it
doesn't make sense to to them and it
only makes sense to us because we've
sort of been worn down right by a lack
of compassion and so I think that having
compassion is you know reigniting and
remembering that that place where we
were we where we didn't understand why
you would harm anyone you know and this
isn't to say my kids don't beat the hell
out of each other I mean but you know
I'm not saying that there are these
idealized creatures but I think that
there is that kind of innocent place
that that we can kind of really relate
to each other with a sense of
understanding and kindness you know so
that's a you know I would think you know
the the highest value thing I hold in
value the most is that kindness you
mentioned about your the hike was like
create your own rite of passage and you
said that our cultures have kind of
missed that any ideas how we can
credibly get that back particularly as
mothers because you talk so touchingly
about your mum yeah I actually think
it's really I mean I think we need to
bring it back you know we need to bring
it back somehow and and you know that
and I think it has to do with being
connected to nature because you know
that the cultures who still do rites of
passage or the cultures who used to do
rites of passage they're almost always
cultures who lived in a more tribal way
and they're far away that has is more
connected to the land in the earth and
nature and all that stuff and you know
you see this you know that the young and
often it is you know like the young boy
has to go out for three days or you know
and fast and meditate and you know the
or or you know kill a elephant or
whatever the hell you know and I think
that obviously we can't we can't all do
that in our urban lives and such but in
to do something for our children that
allows them to you know do all the
things like I talked about that I had
like that I was you know I made
decisions and I suffered the
consequences of them if they were the
wrong decision or I benefited I got the
triumph if they were the right I did it
myself it has a deal to do with
resilience solitude working for working
for you know what you get and and and
also I think that the essentials you
know one of the things on the PCT is
that my main concerns were not they were
not emotional you know they were how do
I get water what am I going to have for
dinner how do I get over this mountain
safely you know it was it was it was
actually survival which which really
can't be replicated I think in our
regular lives for most of us and so you
know I've really thought about this for
my own kids like what I'm what I'm so -
look I'm just gonna drive them out I'm
just say Happy Trails kids see you in a
month but um you know we'll see but no I
mean something like that we've got to do
and I don't know what the answer is but
I do think that we can do it you know I
think that we that that would be a
really helpful thing to a lot of our
kids to you know to force them to be
resilient yeah thanks so much everyone
thank you